you know you can't let the orderliness
part of you get the upper hand so
terribly that it's impossible for you to
live that's what happens to girls who
have anorexia by the way you know how
you get there's this idea with regards
to anorexia that it's often high
achieving girls who have it well it's
hyper conscientious girls they get so
disgust sensitive they can't stand their
own bodies and so for example then they
start being able to look at their bodies
properly and so what they do instead of
looking at their whole body they lose
the ability to do that they only can see
parts of their body and then they can't
tell the difference between a part
that's healthy and well shaped and a fat
part and so anything that's that's
that's what would you call AB dubious
anything that's hard to measure becomes
impossible to see so either the anorexic
line at one point was a very big woman
maybe about this big and thin yes
obviously and so I was trying to work
with her on her body perception disorder
and one of the things I did was so I had
her come and sit beside me so I was
sitting like this and so is she and I
said well you look at our two thighs
which one is bigger like mine was like
40% bigger and she said well I can't
tell they look the same to me and so I
said okay this is what we're going to do
I let her do it I said you take a pencil
and I'll sit on a piece of paper and you
just trace my thigh okay and then you
can put that piece of paper underneath
your thigh and trace it and then you can
look at the difference well so I had her
do that and she looked at the two pieces
of paper and she couldn't believe it she
could not believe that that was actually
the case because her perception had
become so disordered that it was
impossible for her to see the real shape
of her body and we would go outside and
I would ask her you know is that person
thin is that person fat and with other
people she could tell but with her own
body
not a chance she couldn't see it
properly at all and so there's a real
obsession with purity among women who
have anorexia no they'd like to starve
themselves right down to the bone
because the bone is sort of pure and
white and there's no excess tissue on it
and so anorexia also looks like a
disease of disgust so it's very very
difficult to she thought in very
black-and-white terms one of the things
I had her do at one point was said she
hasn't music she said I either reading
like a song or I don't like it at all
and I said okay well you've got a music
collection why don't you go through like
20 of those songs and rate them on a
scale from one to ten and she couldn't
do it
it was either yes or no orderly right
the boundaries around the categories
were absolutely segregated and and her
apartment tended to be decorated in
black and white and she was hyper clean
you know so everything in the apartment
was extraordinarily orderly well put
away she couldn't stand to see anything
disgusting on the counters and that sort
of thing so very very difficult disorder
to treat anorexia very very difficult so
and you know you can see how it can go
wrong because food you know when you're
eating your disgust systems are on alert
you know like you you want the thing you
want to eat and you absolutely don't
want the thing you don't want to eat and
your mouth is very sensitive to that
sort of thing you know the texture in
all of that and your sense of smell is
very sensitive to that sort of thing
because you know you don't want to eat
anything that's contaminated or
poisonous so it's another situation like
sex where the reward system is driving
you forward for to engage in a consumer
Tory behavior but the disgust system is
right there modulating and moderating it
and there's a tension between those two
things that's already always at work
with the anorexic types the disgust
sense the disgust system gets the upper
hand so she was also extraordinarily
judgmental and perfectionistic but that
goes along with it because orderly
people are judgmental and
perfectionistic and so if you're you're
a perfectionist often what that means is
you have very high levels of orderliness
and very high levels of neuroticism and
those two things chased each other
around like mad because you can't stand
the idea that you would make a mistake
and you get anxious about it as well so
then you get stuck in this
perfectionistic mindset and you can't
get out of it so